okay so the new trailer for Avatar to
the way of water is out now and
throughout this video we're gonna be
opening Pandora's Box to break down the
whole thing filled with Easter eggs
callbacks of the first movie and some
details that give away what the plot
will be this is our definitive breakdown
on the final main trailer before the
movie releases next month will this be
the biggest film of all time will usher
in a new era of Cinema will there be 7.8
too much water well we're gonna get into
it please hit the Thumbs Up Button if
you enjoy the video and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdown take this every
day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into Avatar
the way of water okay so we know the
film will take place over a decade after
the first film that was set during 2154
and it followed Jake Sully as he was
brought in to try and gain acceptance by
the navi this was on a mission from the
RDA so that they could bomb the planet
for a special element called an
obtainium I'm not I'm not laughing now
planet Earth is currently a baron
Wasteland at this time it looks like
Celsius shields on a Saturday night
because of the lack of Natural Resources
we've had a journey out into the stars
and this is why the humans have
ultimately decided to Return to the
Planet they've got nothing left and now
the RDA are reconstructing the base at
Hell's Gate which we know will be part
of this film they have returned to this
Outpost and are now using their own
avatars as a way to conquer the planet
the first movie ended with a battle in
the floating mountains that we know will
also be returning to this film as well
this was caused by a naturally occurring
gravitational anomaly on the planet that
was a good place to fight due to the
atmosphere they're messing with the
human's radar however we'll be
broadening our Horizon so to speak and
traveling to several aquatic locations
so that the navi can defend their home
against all the new foes this place will
be known as met kaina and itsu carries
the gravity differences that the
mountains do as the first film had
Mountain banshees we now see see ones
that allow their Rider to sit on top of
them whilst they're submerged in water
these beasts have long snouts with sharp
protruding teeth that make them look
like a cross between between an
alligator or a long nose car you might
also notice that the leader has a demo
care based on the traditional tattoos of
the Maori there'll be several diver
characters in the movie and new cast
editions such as Kate Winslet is ronal
Winslet apparently set a world record
for the longest seen filmed underwater
without oxygen and he managed to go
seven minutes without taking a breath
she will also have her own creature
called an elu that she can tether
herself to this is a creature that we'll
likely see the navi in the movie taming
so that they can tackle the humans using
underwater means there is a section we
know where they'll attack a human base
and they may use these creatures to
sneak in there undetected trees again
play a big part as well with roots
reaching into the sea creating small
pools that the navi can chill in now we
opened the trailer with two characters
diving into the Lush Waters of Pandora
and here we see Kerry this is an adopted
child of Jake and interi who has a lot
going on with her now when we did our
first trailer breakdown we discussed our
Sigourney Weaver was returning and gave
three times about how they may have
cloned or resurrected her throw that out
with the Mephisto theories though as we
now know what's going on with her sigoni
will be playing Kerry a brand new
character who's completely unattached to
who she was originally Carrie will be a
keen dialer and we've had to learn free
diving in order to film many of the
underwater sequences you might also
notice that her voice sounds similar to
sigourneys but they've downplayed her
being the same person whether there
could be a link as she constantly talks
about her feelings now this is likely a
link to Aya who is basically the all
mother of the planet this is a daily of
Pandora that lurks over everything
however it could also be a link to
sigourney's character in the first film
she was absorbed into the tree when they
tried to transfer her body this could
mean that her spirit is in everything
and the reason that Kerry sounds so
similar is because she has taken a trait
from her she knows people will think
she's crazy but she talks about how she
feels her and how she can also hear her
heartbeat therefore I do think that it's
linked to the two characters and the
recasting was done for a reason this
video is sponsored by established titles
a fun and novel way to preserve the
natural Woodlands of Scotland while
helping Global reforestation efforts
establish titles lets you call yourself
a lady Lord or a LED due to a
traditional Scottish custom you see
landowners used to refer to themselves
as this and established titles allows
you to buy at least one square foot of
dedicated land and a private estate in
edleston Scotland on top of this it's a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles for planetary with
every single order they work with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst also helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland and it
also comes with a bit of an ego boost on
top of all this environmental stuff you
can officially change your name on
credit cards plane tickets your dating
profile whatever you want they also give
you a certificate confirming your Lord's
ship and a unique plot Number that
confirms your exact plot of land but
before Kevin spoilers you punk I am the
Lord of this realm now in addition to
this established titles have also told
me that the first 200 people who use my
link in the description below will be
given a plot within walking distance of
mine it makes an amazing last minute
gift and established titles is actually
running a massive Black Friday sale
right now plus if you use the code heavy
spoilers you get an additional 10 off go
to establishtitles.com heavy spoilers to
get your gifts now and help support the
channel thanks now in the decade since
we last saw them Jake and the teary have
had several children together these are
net am loac and tukatari or tuck for
sure because I've butchered the
pronunciation on all those they also
show a scene in which it looks like they
have one on the way which we see from
the fact that interior is pregnant
whilst hunting however at the end of the
trailer shows that she's no longer
carrying a child making me think that
there's one of two things going on here
now either she lost the baby during a
battle or this initial scene is a
flashback to when she was pregnant with
one of the kids the shot at the end has
Jake with weapon and satchels that the
humans carry showing that the scene
likely happens later on in the movie now
they also have another child a strong
child if you will who doesn't seem like
he's related but I can't put my finger
on why now this is actually Javier who
was a child when Hell's Gate went to
well hell and though it seems like the
humans all left at the end of the first
movie we know that somewhat abandoned to
Pandora do the RDA pulling out faster
than Adidas when Kanye says he's booked
an interview he was rescued by Jake and
natiri and then brought into their
family because of the atmosphere on
Pandora he has to wear an oxygen mask at
all times however he does enjoy the
freedom that the planet gives however
the more industrial things that the
humans offer a Stephen Lang and Matt
Gerald are both returning to the film
despite dying in the first one we've
also had some details filled in on them
too and it could possibly give us an
idea of where the Rocks go in the film
and its sequels now it's been revealed
that Colonel Miles and Corporal Lyle
were put through a program that
resurrects them into something known as
a recombinant this procedure puts the
memories and personality of someone into
a navi Avatar so that they can fight
once more for the RDA Lang is confirmed
that miles will have the same Vendetta
that he had against Jake in the first
movie and that this will drive the new
recombinant not only does he share the
luck that he originally had face wise
but he even has an eagle tattoo on his
arm that Miles had an Affairs film now
because of this I think we can assume
that he could go on an arc of realizing
that he's just being used as a weapon
even in death the soldier hasn't had any
rest and no matter what happens to him
the RDA can just bring him back to life
and force him into the field he's just
an object they own and therefore I can
see him possibly questioning his motives
however Lang has said that he will be
the main antagonist in all four sequels
and that will watch him go on a really
Unexpected Journey because of this he
could really go a number of different
ways that we can't really predict it's
even possible that they may have cloned
him several times and he could end up
coming across a version of himself that
makes him realize the odd RDA on him in
the first movie they made scan to
people's brains to put them into avatars
so I'm guessing this is how he's been
duplicated I also have a really
interesting
so in the first movie we opened by
learning that Jake's twin brother has
just died the reason Jake was picked to
be an avatar was because his brother was
already formatted to one and due to them
sharing the same genetic makeup Jay
could take over without any issues so my
theories are Jake's brother actually
returns from the dead and we learn that
the RDA has placed him into a
recombinant this would add a lot of
dramatic tension to it I mean that Jake
has to fight against the person he lost
who led him to areas today only trouble
is that they'd have to find someone who
looks exactly like Sam Worthington leave
your comments Below on who you think
they should hire to play Sam
worthington's twin brother because a map
me wits end with it shut the [ __ ] up
whilst you're at it and that's the end
of YouTube I'm a comfy idiot but it's
your fault for clicking the video
foreign
we see a giant whale-like creature that
is later used as a weapon on the human
vessel they have clearly mastered the
creatures of sea and air and will be
using them as a way to stop the humans
taking over there's a great shot that
juxtaposes their charge and in it we see
two Mech suits running along a burning
ship yours to see Jake's head popping
out the water which resembles the scene
from Apocalypse Now over the top of this
we see the navi going out and to get
this line from the chieftain
we cannot let you bring your War here
now we know that the leader of the Met
kaina tribe will be played by Cliff
curse this will be Eternal worry and his
wife Freya will be pregnant still we
know she'll be riding into battle
showing how much everyone has to pull
together to fight off this threat now we
see Jay crushing a human skull and this
could potentially belong to his old body
it looks quite old and I think him doing
this is turning his back on the past we
also hear low act talking about how he's
an outcast he would be seen as being
half human so potentially this is why
the navi don't end up accepting him over
Ty Sarah
tyria says she sees him butchered that
and she's probably gonna be a big love
interest for the character in the film
he's the one who also says that the way
water connects all things and we see
several shots of the navi and life of
water cohabiting cut is that a win now
there's also some great shots including
one of the boat in the first film the
humans of course had a giant Airship but
yet they've changed things up to fight
against the navian in the sea I have a
feeling that natiri might be captured
and they will have to rescue her this
could also be the heart that Kerry is
referring to but let me know below if
you have your own thoughts and theories
now that ends the trailer and we know
that we have three more sequels after
this these are Avatar the seed mirror
Avatar the token Rider and lastly Avatar
the Quest for air the latter is the
deity of the planet who is seen as the
all mother of Pandora that will
apparently release in 2028 and I'm
curious to see how they're gonna keep
going with this I always say never bet
against James Cameron because time and
time again he's been looked as being
someone who can't possibly make back the
money he spends on a movie however he
always does it and no I'm not I haven't
got a crazy amount of hype yet yeah I am
interested to see how this all plays out
I think this is probably going to be a
must-see at the cinema and it feels like
one of those films that's going to be an
event to close at the air Cameron has
constantly been at the Forefront of
pioneering certain Technologies for film
and the reason for this delay was down
on them having to find way used to do
motion capture underwater the film looks
gorgeous too and unfortunately YouTube's
compression downplays how good this
thing actually looks I was lucky enough
to see the first trailer in IMAX and it
did look incredible now we still don't
really know that much about the movie
and even though we have more details on
it than we did with the first trailer I
still think there's a lot of mystery to
the entire thing because of this it's
difficult to break down as it's not like
a Marvel movie where we can look at
what's come before in both the films and
Comics however I hope this breakdown has
filled in some details and given you
some tidbits on what might be happening
in the film obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the trailer so make
sure you comment below and let me know
by running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of top gun
Maverick on the 15th of November and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the teaser you make the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on the screen right now
so that's you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch make sure you check out
our Brighton of all the trailers of
black panther wakanda forever we discuss
all the new TV spots give our theories
on them and yeah it's definitely worth
checking out if you're excited about
that film by the way thanks for staying
through the video I've been Paul I'll
see you next time take care peace